now at 7 30 here on CBS mornings and on
his way to Northern Ireland yesterday
President Biden spoke to the family of a
journalist the U.S says is wrongfully
detained in Russia Evan gershkovich of
the Wall Street Journal is the first
American reporter to face Russian
charges of Espionage since the Cold War
charges at the Wall Street Journal as
well as the U.S government strongly deny
in a statement yesterday gershkovich's
family said in addition to being a
distinguished journalist Evan is a
beloved Son and brother there's a hole
in our hearts and in our family that
won't be filled until we are reunited
and on the subject of reunited being
reunited Ambassador Roger Carstens the
state Department's special presidential
Envoy for hostage Affairs joins us now
to talk about what's being done to bring
Evan back home good morning Mr
Ambassador thank you very much for being
here Evan born in New Jersey taken from
a restaurant in Russia in late March and
very little of any contact with them
since then what can you tell us about
efforts to get him home right now
hey Tony it's uh good to be with you
this morning uh since Evan's been taken
we've had kind of a full court press
within the state department and U.S
government writ large as you probably
know the very date that he was taken uh
members of the state department met with
members of The Wall Street Journal his
employer to discuss what we knew at that
point the very next day secretary
Lincoln issued a statement condemning
and the action and asking for more
information from the Russians since then
uh senior members of the US government
to include Secretary of Lincoln have met
with their counterparts in Russia to try
to press them to release Evan and to
gain more information we've also been
trying to gain Consular access to him
and you have yet had any luck in that so
we're currently working hard but maybe
the most important thing you want to
know is that on Monday the 10th of April
secretary blinken determined Evan to be
a wrongfully detained American citizen
and now that brings to Bear more tools
in the US government to try to affect
his release
you say that the US government has a
full court press out right now and has
been pressing their Russian counterparts
to bring Evan home can you detail any
more about what that means what do you
mean by pressing what's exactly being
done
I think when I say the word press it's
uh I would say in the last few days
because he wasn't yet declared to be
wrongfully detained we've had verbal
engagements we've had written
engagements the Russians but now that it
is wrongfully detained we start to work
on negotiating strategies and working
with the Russians to to find Evan's
release and not only Evan but Paul
Whelan as well as Paul's been held by
the Russians for almost five years now
we understand Evan is being held at
least initially according to the Wall
Street Journal in the same prison that
Paul Whelan was held in do you what can
you tell us about the conditions there
how urgent is the situation when it
comes to Evan and his health in terms of
how he's being treated right now we just
don't really have a sense however from
talking to Paul uh Whelan I talked to
him by the way just last Monday two days
ago he called from Russia but in talking
to Paul and talking to Trevor and
talking to Brittany Greiner that's a
tough prison uh they if there's one
thing that I can say that prison's
famous for it's isolation and keeping
prisoners in a state of isolation and
that can have a psychological effect
yeah Mr Ambassador is a prisoner swap on
the table right now
you know I really can't get into the
specifics of the negotiation and what
our strategy is and for the main reason
that every time we negotiate in public
we might be lessening our chances to
actually get a return what I can't tell
you is that a lot of options are on the
table they're being considered and we
have a pretty good track record right
now under the Biden Administration we've
brought back 26 Americans in 26 months
so we're going to find a way to bring
Evan and Paul Whelan home
what can be done to prevent this kind of
thing from happening again in particular
in Russia how can you make the cost of
doing this not worth it
you know we're working on a deterrent
strategy secretary blinken asked me a
while back to work on a deterrent
strategy that would raise the price of
taking people for political gain from
other countries for example and make
make the price so high that in the
future those countries would not be
taking Americans or frankly citizens of
any other country right now what we have
done is we've developed something called
the D indicator and if you go to
travel.state.gov you'll have a chance to
see which countries have a d indicator
which indicates that there's an
increased chance of being taken as a
wrongful detainee
all right Mr Ambassador that's a good
resource there I hear you on the
long-term Solutions and I also hear you
on the urgency of working right now to
free Evan gershkovic and Paul Whalen we
appreciate your efforts Ambassador
Carson's thank you very much thank you
Tony take care
[Music]